blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so we're once again in the middle
of a climate change summit and as is
often the case during these climate
change summits we are starting to see
articles
uh outraged um about the fact that many
world leaders and others like jeff bezos
flew to in this case it's glasgow
scotland to the climate change summit on
private jets and the contrast that is
illuminated by these articles
is of course about we're trying to
figure out climate change and yet
private jet on a per person basis
outrageous carbon footprint a private
jet where you might have two pilots and
a flight attendant and two people or you
know maybe a small entourage
on a per-person basis an outrageous
uh expenditure
of carbon emissions and um it is
something that happens every time there
is one of these climate summits and it's
an issue and i'm going to talk about it
but i actually believe that it's part of
the distraction from the real issue and
i'll explain to you in a moment so
here's just one sample article
around 400 private jets
carrying heads of state billionaires
business leaders and celebrities have
converged on glasgow for a global
warming summit amazon founder jeff
bezos's 65 million us dollar gulf stream
jet was among the hundreds of vip jets
reportedly carrying more than a thousand
attendees and their staff to the cop26
meeting cop26 with others including
microsoft founder bill gates actor
arnold schwarzenegger also expected to
fly in
it can't be stressed enough how bad
private jets are for the environment it
is the worst way to travel by miles says
matt finch from the uk's transport and
environment campaign group the average
private jet and we are not talking air
force one emits two tons of co2 every
hour in flight private jets are very
prestigious but it is difficult to avoid
the hypocrisy of using one while
claiming to be fighting climate change
he said for context the total carbon
footprint of an ordinary citizen
including everywhere they travel and
everything they consume is around eight
tons a year so basically like just your
flight to cop26 is two tons
per hour per hour
and um most normal people
um consume you know about eight tons a
year in carbon emissions in total the
400 private aircraft are expected to
emit 13 000 tons of carbon dioxide but
uk secretary of state liz trust defended
the number of planes flying in saying
it's important that we have people face
to face i think everybody who's ever
done a zoom call knows they're quite
useful for some things but when you
really get into crunch negotiations when
you want to look somebody in the eye and
talk to them face to face you do need to
meet in person so listen um i i hate to
tell people
the solution is not going to be to ban
private jets
so let's take it piece by piece
does this happen at every climate change
summit yes do people get angry every
time yes is there something legitimately
hypocritical about saying we want to
deal with climate but i'm going to
expend
a family's worth of annual co2 emissions
just to fly myself in this case to
glasgow scotland yes that that's all
absolutely true and legitimate but
there's two different things that are
going on here first is just a kind of
like a pragmatism
the
economics of private jets for these
elites for lack of a better term
um dignitaries billionaires politicians
etc the economics of the private jet
makes sense and it's been calculated uh
ad nauseam fiera ceo
and you've got to go to the airport uh
typically the airports you fly out of
commercially are far more congested and
in traffic laden areas and you've got to
get there an hour and a half before the
flight or maybe longer depending on
what's going on um and then you've got
to do security boarding all these
different things then get out of the
airport just the additional time
on the basis of of what ceos get paid
makes it worth it to do the private jet
now you could say well they shouldn't be
getting paid that much okay these are
all debates we can have but i want to
first start from just like a completely
pragmatic thing the private jets aren't
going away for these people private jets
aren't going to be banned i don't even
know what the
legal framework would be to ban private
jets like this just this stuff just
isn't going to happen we might want to
do some of these things it's not going
to happen so the solution here is not
going to be
to ban private jets all right that's
number one in terms of like the
technological question here the solution
on private jet emissions is going to be
renewable fuels solar-powered planes
prototypes already exist at some point
it's going to be a real thing we have to
be realistic as far as that goes i am
110 on board in saying look at the per
person carbon emissions for getting
these people to glasgow it's obscene
it's crazy it's particularly
counterproductive when we're talking
about dealing with climate fine but it's
not going to change
now
um
the more important thing
is
for me the private jet thing
is
almost as big of a distraction as saying
you should recycle
your orange juice
containers
and the boxes your amazon stuff comes in
and stop using plastic straws as a look
away from the real problem issue which
is 100 companies are responsible for 71
percent of global emissions and you not
using plastic straws is not really going
to change that reminder
the guardian's been on this for four
years
100 companies are responsible for 71
percent of global emissions a relatively
small number of fossil fuel producers
and their investors could hold the key
to tackling climate change just 100
companies have been the source of more
than 70 percent of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions since 1988 the
carbon majors report pinpoints how a
relatively small set of fossil fuel
producers may hold the key to systemic
change on carbon emissions we've known
this for a very long time
even commercial air travel
accounts for only three to four percent
of total u.s greenhouse gas emissions so
here we're talking about private jets
private jets are a smaller emitter of
carbon emissions than the commercial
airline industry commercial airliners
are responsible for three to four
percent of u.s greenhouse gas emissions
the private jets are a fraction of that
so the finger pointing at the jets and
the air travel for me
is almost the same distraction as saying
you're not did you just throw out that
paper bag instead of recycling it or
reusing it the biggest polluters are
thrilled to have articles about plastic
straws
they're thrilled to have articles about
people are
trashing half of what they could be
recycling and they're almost as thrilled
to have articles about look at the
private jets being sent to glasgow are
the optics bad of course
of course they're bad but the private
jets aren't going away they can
eventually be shifted to renewable
sources of energy we already have the
prototypes it's going to be a while and
it is another one of these distractions
from the fact that unregulated or barely
regulated or not enough regulated major
industry has not been told by
governments
you're not going to be able to keep
polluting in this way 100 companies 71
percent of global emissions so i'm not
laughing off the private jet thing but
it's important to contextualize it
lastly
i also don't care that much about the
private jets
if really substantive change comes from
the talks which it rarely does
often these talks are we all agree very
seriously very strongly that climate
change is a problem
let's set
vague
maybe achievable completely
unenforceable goals
and end up putting barely a dent in the
greenhouse gas emissions that we're
pumping into the atmosphere so
i really wouldn't care about the private
jets if we had something enforceable and
more serious come out of these talks the
the cycle is likely to continue
it's not actually because of the private
jets the private jets to me are more of
a sign of the gap between rich and poor
some people can't afford 400 a month for
rent and meanwhile you have people
flying to glasgow for the climate change
talks spending 500 or a thousand or 2
000
an hour in gas alone
for the private jet never mind the
pilots and the uh airport fees and all
these different things so yes it's
absurd but let's contextualize the
absurdity if you disagree with me let me
know
all right um i am going to
deal with an issue
that many people emailed me about
and i don't know if i'm going to take a
position that my audience will find
refreshing
or if people are going to be mad at me
some people will be mad
um joe biden was pretty clearly falling
asleep
yesterday at the opening speeches of the
cop 26 climate change summit
he was clearly not just resting his eyes
i'm playing the video here for the
audience
his head was nodding forward there's
really no doubt about it okay joe biden
was sleepy during yesterday's cop 26
morning speeches
i don't think the left really gains
anything from denying it and pretending
that reality is not what it is joe biden
was tired
and the speeches were pretty boring
and he's only been in europe for a
couple of days it's you know five to
seven hours ahead of east coast
depending on which country you're in
your body in the best case adjusts one
hour a day so in the morning when this
was going on for joe biden's body clock
it was like three or four in the morning
now could he have had coffee uh sure
maybe he did maybe he didn't we don't
know
um
i think that if we start engaging
on joe biden wasn't really falling
asleep and it became pretty clear at one
point a staffer went over and kind of
started talking to him or saying
something to kind of wake him up uh and
uh maybe offering coffee joe biden seems
to kind of say no at one point it's not
clear what the conversation was but it's
pretty clear that this is what it is if
we just say it's not what's going on we
look kind of stupid for me the argument
is
uh okay so he was tired
but he's much better than the guy that
he was running against donald trump
like what exactly is the argument i
think that we need to make these this
issue about substance rather than just
denying reality if you start engaging
and he wasn't really falling asleep
it just doesn't it's just kind of a dumb
conversation he was falling asleep okay
he was he was clearly falling asleep
address it head-on okay biden was
falling asleep
he didn't say anything humiliating or
embarrassing at this
uh climate change summit which trump
wouldn't even have been invited to
because he said that climate change was
a hoax created by china in order to hurt
american manufacturing trump the country
of the u.s was out of these discussions
under trump because of the things that
trump said he believed about climate
change um and i can't think of any real
issue on which i would rather have trump
in charge than joe biden including
acutely what we're talking about here
when it comes to the climate so that's
my position on this and some people
might write in and say david you really
shouldn't admit that joe biden was
falling asleep
um but that's what was going on
and i don't think we really gain
anything from denying the reality i
would just
again and and so what i'd rather have
biden sleepy while other people are
speaking than trump there or have the
u.s not be involved at all so let me
know your thoughts on that if i'm
missing something let me know you can
find me on twitter at deepakman we're
going to take a quick break and be back
right after this
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
we um over the last few years there's
been sort of a almost like a cultural
battle around the fbi and intelligence
agencies uh the fbi much maligned by
donald trump and trumpists for its
allegedly politically biased involvement
in uh electoral politics even though if
you actually think back to 2016 uh the
fbi's involvement may have been what
handed donald trump a victory remember
james comey's second completely
unnecessary
press conference about the investigation
into hillary clinton's emails but let's
put that aside for now
um modern day
we have seen the fbi become a flashpoint
of controversy
particularly in the context of the
january 6 riots there is now a
blockbuster new investigation from the
washington post
which shows that actually the fbi
received very specific tips about the
violence that was expected to happen on
january 6th which did remember the day
of the trump riots but the fbi as far as
the washington post has uncovered
declined to act
this is
stunning
this is stunning let's look at some of
the information a sprawling new
investigation by the washington post
into the events leading up to the
capital insurrection
has revealed that the fbi received
numerous and highly detailed tips on the
potential for serious violence by
followers of then-president donald trump
on january 6. and despite the
specificity and volume of reports the
fbi largely dismissed the warnings the
fact that law enforcement of all stripes
reportedly underestimated the likelihood
of violence on january 6 has already
been widely reported but the post's
massive project started last spring
based on interviews of more than 230
people describes in excruciating detail
just how much was ignored in one of the
more shocking revelations the post
recounts how information began flooding
in to the fbi as early as december 6
when the agency received a tip about a
message in an online post telling trump
supporters please be in dc armed on the
six
you might have to kill the palace guards
are you okay with that and indeed there
was violence against the so-called
palace guards u.s capitol police there
to defend the capital another message
reported by the post stated in an
apparent reference to killing officers
drop a handful the rest will flee
meaning
kill a few u.s capitol police and then
they're going to get out of our way
on december 19 trump tweeted a message
exhorting his followers to come to dc on
january 6 writing quote big protest in
dc on january 6 be there will be wild
that lit up online pro-trump groups and
fbi informants quickly began passing on
information about highly specific
planning for a violent attack in
washington here's how the post puts it
the fbi received a call alerting them to
trump supporters making plans online to
bring arms to washington and arrest
lawmakers
that the sunday afternoon call was
handled by the bureau's national threat
operations center a clearinghouse for
tips about crimes according to a
document titled threats to take guns and
overrun the dc police january 4 to
january 20th
it's almost like the 911 memo bin laden
poised to strike
threats to take guns and overrun dc
police
the file was updated the following
afternoon by an fbi employee seeking to
reclassify the information more domestic
terrorism than criminal in nature they
wanted to say hey this is almost not
even just criminal this is domestic
terrorism
criminal has received a number of
guardians as a significant number of
guardians as a result of threats to
congress and other government officials
the caller according to the fbi document
said people were planning on meeting in
certain areas and sneaking guns into dc
in an attempt to overrun the dc police
beginning january 4th through 20th on
three different sites there is
discussion about recruitment where to
meet at bring guns and arresting
senators and members of congress to hold
trials outside in public areas in one
specific threat utah republican senator
mitt romney often regarded by trump
supporters as a traitor to magda
was named as a target
yet despite all of this on december 22nd
the post says the fbi
closed its internal threat assessment of
the matter determining it did not
warrant further investigation at this
time
an fbi official told the post that
before doing so steps were taken to
share the info but ultimately the
determination was made that the tips
they received featured vague and
primarily first amendment protected
speech
um when we think back and we say
how were they not more ready
and why was the national guard not
deployed in advance and even as the
capital was being overrun
and as we follow the chain of command
upward we learned that on the day of
it was donald trump who was reportedly
gleefully watching the first couple of
hours of the riots maybe thinking it
would actually prevent joe biden from
ultimately being certified as president
of the united states
later trump started to not really like
that the writers looked low class and
made him look bad
but the pressure was building for him
to deploy the national guard he was told
mike pence is potentially in danger mike
pence had to be evacuated they were
chanting hang mike pence but we know
that trump was actually mad at mike
pence trump was furious that pence
wasn't willing to do what trump believed
pence could do to really stop the
certification of joe biden as president
even though pence accurately told him i
can't do that sir i can't do that
and the calls built for trump to call
off the protesters and to send in the
national guard and it was trump who
resisted doing that on january 6th but
this is a much broader backstory of a
sort of hot potato that was being played
behind the scenes the fbi
was at the time that they could say this
is criminal not domestic terrorism
sort of letting the dc police know you
might want to do something about this
the fbi was saying to department of
justice
uh you know maybe you need to look into
this and coordinate fencing or whatever
the case may be
capitol hill police seemed
not to actually even be told what the
fbi was aware of and then there was this
last minute request for national guard
which was initially resisted although
ultimately the national guard was
deployed
and there are some people who are
writing this is just like what happened
on 9 11 where agencies couldn't
communicate they couldn't coordinate
there weren't systems in place but this
is actually a clearly different thing
after 9 11 systems were put in place so
that different agencies could coordinate
with each other
this seems more that there was a lack of
willingness to do those things for
reasons we don't yet totally know and
possibly because somebody ordered them
to stand down so let's
i will now explain to you
the more benign explanation and then the
the really horrible one
the more benign explanation here
is
the fbi
genuinely
didn't think
that there was the potential for january
6 to become what it was and they made a
mistake in judgment they didn't take it
seriously enough now what's interesting
about that is that it would sort of run
counter to the idea that the fbi and all
of these intel agencies and others were
out there to make trump look as bad as
possible and all these different things
it sounds like you know if the fbi
wanted to make trump really bad they
would have publicized this in advance
they would have made trumpus look bad et
cetera they didn't do that
the sort of sinister possibility for
which we don't yet have evidence right
these are the speculative ideas
um is that someone
once they caught wind that the fbi was
receiving these
threats information about these threats
um and starting to act on them someone
told the fbi stand down
turn this over to someone else sort of
but don't really give him much
information uh because we want
the riots to be able to happen because
we think maybe they actually will stop
the certification of the election
we don't know the answer to that yet but
every week we are getting more and more
information about the fact that many
people and by people we mean elected
officials
associates of trump
and law enforcement had reason to fear
that this was going to get really really
bad on january 6 and it did
um and the right preparations were not
ultimately in place at some point we may
know the full story we still don't know
it as of right now
one more january 6 story that i want to
go over
it is now being reported
that republican senator
lindsey graham
allegedly told police on january 6th
about the rioters
you've got guns use them you've got guns
use them now why would we care about
this there's actually two reasons which
i will tell you in a moment let's first
look a report at a report about this um
that aired on cnn
graham according to your report yelled
at the senate sergeant-at-arms what are
you doing take back the senate you've
got guns use them the south carolina
senator was adamant
we give you guns for a reason he
repeated use them
another stark contrast to show how the
republican party
you know they've been whitewashing
january 6 ever since that day but at
that time
somebody like lindsey graham was
obviously very afraid of what was going
on and was calling on law enforcement
there to resort to some very extreme
measures so there's a few really
important and interesting things here
first of all
a lot of these republicans who in
retrospect claim january 6 wasn't that
bad
we weren't really that much at risk etc
leaking leaking leaking drip drip drip
we're figuring out
their actions
and their words both spoke to the degree
of insanity that took place on that day
give you an example
congressman mo brooks we found out wore
body armor that day
why do you wear body armor unless you
expect things to get really crazy now mo
brooks has since said my wife wanted me
to wear it
but why did your wife think that there
was going to be violent i mean it's not
really
an explanation that takes
mo brooks out of knowing in advance that
there was a real potential for violence
that's one example
um now we have lindsey graham lindsey
graham who has downplayed everything he
said listen some people acted
inappropriately but most of what
happened was constitutionally protected
speech and speech alone etc etc he was
afraid enough that he was telling police
officers to start shooting protesters
and the story that they tell in
retrospect clearly doesn't match up with
their actions on that day nor does it
match up with the words that are now
being ascribed to them there's a good
newsweek article about this uh which
says senator lindsey graham reportedly
called for rioters to be shot as
lawmakers were forced to evacuate the
senate chamber on january 6th the
washington post sunday published the
results of a lengthy investigation
reconstructing what happened before
during and after the riot the second
part titled bloodshed goes into detail
about how then vice president mike pence
and members of congress were evacuated
as we know
according to the post graham a
republican from south carolina was
furious that senators were forced to
flee their own chamber he yelled at the
sergeant-at-arms and urged him to shoot
rioters in the mob the newspaper
reported citing a republican senator
with knowledge of the exchange what are
you doing take back the senate you've
got guns use them we give you guns for a
reason use them immediately after the
riot graham turned against donald trump
and refused to join his gop colleagues
and objecting to the certification of
biden's win
trump and i we've had a hell of a
journey i hate to end it this way uh oh
my god i hate it from my point of view
he's been a consequential president but
today all i can say is count me out
enough is enough but
he soon fell back in line defending
trump as he was impeached a historic
second time over the capital
insurrection earlier this year graham
insisted trump remains the most popular
republican in the country and is
essential to the gop going forward to
try to erase donald trump from the
republican party is insane and the
people who try to erase him are going to
wind up getting erased it's impossible
for this party to move forward without
president trump being its leader because
the people who are conservatives have
chosen him as their leader so when we
think about what happened on january 6th
and as we learn more about it and we
learn about who knew what when and what
were people expecting at different
points in time
remember that their actions and their
words on that day tell us much more than
their words today it was no big deal
these were mostly peaceful protests etc
lindsey graham saying shoot the
protesters mo brooks wearing body armor
etc etc they've been lying all along in
the aftermath of january 6th
that belief that understanding just is
reinforced more and more with every
passing day we're going to take a quick
break i have so much more to cover today
for more on all of today's stories make
sure you're following us on instagram at
david pakman show and you can follow me
on instagram at david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
joinpakman.com when it comes to vaccine
mandates there are really two or three
major questions are they legal
um are they moral
and do they work now are they legal is
something that in the united states is
essentially settled now you'll hear
people say um it's unconstitutional
these are the same people that say the
2020 election was unconstitutional he
asked them well what what exactly was
violated from the constitution they
don't know
but the legality of vaccine requirements
particularly when there's a test out
policy um
is is really without question at this
point in time even without a test out
policy for things like attending school
or whatever the case may be we've had
examples of these going back more than
100 years in the united states in
different places the legality no matter
what you hear on wherever facebook uh
right-wing media et cetera the legality
is really not in question
the morality is a different type of
question when we think about questions
that we want to answer the first thing
we have is we have to determine what
kind of a question it is it is a
question with an empirical answer uh how
much hydrogen is there in atmospheric
air that we breathe or whatever that's
one type of question um is it wrong to
steal bread to feed your family well
okay that's a if you're morally that's a
judgment call and the question of
morality is more of a judgment call and
it can be debated and it's not what
we're doing today
the third question is do vaccine
mandates work
and there are many on the right who have
sought to make it seem like vaccine
mandates don't work by talking about the
number of
whatever
that are threatening to quit if they
have to get vaccinated saying they will
quit
writing a letter stating they will quit
and every single time that that happens
i take the position of let's not go by
what the union is threatening let's not
go by what people are posting on social
media let's just go by the number of
people that actually quit and we have a
new data point and it's from the new
york police department despite threats
and hyperbole that up to a third of nypd
might quit over the vaccine mandate 10
000 officers might quit
as of this morning
34
officers have defied the vaccine mandate
out of 36 000 meaning
0.09 percent
there is literally no effect on service
at this point says new york city police
commissioner dermot shea
new york city's vaccine mandate for
municipal workers has taken effect
and just 34 police officers have refused
it a far cry from the 10 000 threatened
by the nypd's union
under the mandate announced by mayor
bill de blasio all city municipal
employees including police firefighters
and civil servants must either get
vaccinated or be put on unpaid leave
hundreds of city workers protested the
mandate and the new york police
department's largest union the police
benevolent association claimed it would
take thousands of cops off the streets
as of thursday morning the pba warned
last week there were 10 000 unvaccinated
uniformed nypd members which equals the
staffing of dozens of patrol precincts
who will be barred from reporting for
duty on monday november 1 unless they
have applied for a religious or medical
exemption
the union's president patrick lynch
particularly slammed police commission
commissioner dermot shea for going along
with the plan commissioner shea and his
team should have told the mayor this
mandate and his arbitrary friday
deadline were going to throw nypd
operations into chaos on monday however
the chaos failed to materialize less
than three dozen nypd officers were put
on unpaid leave and the department
reported no interruption in service here
is andrew giuliani rudy giuliani's son
who's running for governor
uh
saying 27 percent of nypd may be gone
take a look police department issuing
staffing um we're looking at potentially
losing 27
of the nypd at this moment i think 73
of the nypd has actually lost uh you
know has the vaccine
so my position has continued to be let's
see how many of them actually do it and
the real number is 34
out of 36 000. now remember
what is the question we are answering
the fact that it's only 34 doesn't mean
the vaccine mandate is morally right i
believe it is but it's important that we
understand what is the question we're
asking and what is the question that we
are answering the vaccine mandate is
working now these 34 officers
they may well find themselves looking
around
wondering what happened to my pension
what happened to my salary
what happened to my health care coverage
they may regret this decision okay but
the point is it's only 34 individuals
i also would expect that many of these
34
are mad
at the rest of the 36 000
that went ahead and got vaccinated okay
that is a really common thing in these
situations where those who are the ones
that are the outliers those who are the
ones that are doing what i believe is
not good for their communities or their
families or their jobs or for anything
they will be mad at everybody else for
caving to the man and complying etc um
also big picture
step back and think about the numbers
for a moment
eighty percent of u.s adults have
received at least one dose so far eighty
percent of u.s adults are what we would
call at least partially vaccinated right
now
there's probably a bunch of lying going
on about people claiming not to be
vaccinated and actually being vaccinated
for social pressure reasons anecdotally
we know this is true we saw a very
interesting report on a recent live
stream of a cnn reporter who went to
i don't remember where it was some state
in the south and re-interviewed a guy
who was very much against the vaccine
six nine months ago and he said i did
get it i did get it but i have not told
anyone in my life
because of the social pressure not to
get the vaccine i mean mathematically
when 80 of us adults have gotten at
least one vaccine dose
you know
that there are people who are simply
lying about it these 34 police officers
in new york city to go back to that for
a moment i i got a very interesting
email which i'll uh read in full for you
on friday
in my mailbag
and they said you know we talk about the
few bad apples that spoil the bunch in
police departments the 34 who refuse to
get vaccinated these might be exactly
the types of officers we want gone
anyway uh because we talk about the
george floyd situation or whatever the
case may be and i continue to believe
because of what i see that most officers
have the right intentions and want to do
what's right
these 34 who are refusing to do what's
right
morally in my opinion
might be the exact types of officers
that we would want not on the force as
uh as it is now again for those who
think the vaccine mandates don't work
clearly they do uh we have seen health
systems with about a one percent uh
refusal rate and uh it seems to be the
exactly the type of people we want gone
who are leaving anyway right i mean
nurses
who refuse to do what's right for
patient safety are the ones who are
ending up unvaccinated and quitting or
getting fired from hospital systems
that's good
that's good sounds like a good thing not
to have those folks providing care the
police officers who either don't want
rules to apply to them
or
believe wrongly that there's something
illegal about such a requirement these
are the ones that are quitting maybe
these are the ones that we want to see
quit as it is the mandates are working
really well
and um whenever you hear oh 20 or saying
or currently unvaccinated
let's wait to see how many actually end
up out of their jobs it's a very small
number and the argument can strongly be
made that these are folks we probably
don't want in those jobs anyway
so
democratic senator
uh
ostensibly democratic senator joe
manchin yesterday
gave a press conference on this spending
and infrastructure bill that he has been
uh an obstacle to actually getting
passed gave a press conference yesterday
that i can only describe to you as
kafka-esque now what what does
kafka-esque mean um fans of the tv
series breaking bad might recognize the
word kafka-esque i've used it a few
times before it's really the only word i
can think of to describe this and you'll
see why in a second uh kafka-esque means
having a nightmarishly complex
bizarre or illogical quality
of the example that merriam-webster
gives is that sometimes there are
kafka-esque bureaucratic delays
um
my birth country of argentina
i think is arguably best known for
kafkaesque bureaucracy problems but
that's a story for a different day i'm
going to play some clips for you from
this joe manchin
uh press conference
in this clip i mean everything is just
backwards
joe manchin says hey listen
he's been working on this bill for three
months
and
he's urging the house to vote and pass
the bipartisan infrastructure bill take
a listen to this i've worked in good
faith for three months for the past
three months
with president biden leader schumer
speaker pelosi and my colleagues on the
reconciliation bill and i will continue
to do so
for the sake of the country i urge the
house to vote and pass the bipartisan
infrastructure bill
[Laughter]
joe you've been one of the primary
holdups in actually getting to a bill
that
everybody will be happy with in terms of
democrats in the senate
and he now is framing this as the fact
that the house
won't vote and pass the bill he wants to
be law
means
he is no longer part of the problem
think about the backwards framing his
framing is listen when joe biden wants
to talk to me i talk to him i negotiate
with democrats i negotiate with
republicans and yet the house won't vote
on the bipartisan infrastructure bill
ignoring the fact that there's multiple
components here and multiple bills that
there is a desire to pass these in
tandem and that he has been like a
stubborn little kid that nobody can
placate who just wants attention and is
clearly enjoying the attention but he's
saying it's everybody else's fault not
mine
next clip
here he says he won't support any bill
unless he has clarity as to the impact
on inflation of that bill i for one
won't support a multi-trillion dollar
bill without greater clarity about why
congress chooses to ignore the serious
effects of inflation
and debt that have on our economy and
existing government programs these are
just the same old tired talking points
we know
uh the effect of government programs and
of government spending has he sought
clarity on it
uh has he spoken to economic experts
about this because these answers are
available these are not things to which
we can't find clarity and now
throwing in the typically republican
political football of our the debt the
debt the debt our debt
and then in completely
you know
it's just
i don't even know what to call it
fashion joe manchin says hey let's quit
playing games and pass the bill yeah joe
you're the one playing the games
it's time to pass the bill and quit
playing games
irony is dead
irony is dead joe manchin says let's
stop the games and pass the bill
now does he recognize the absurdity of
what he's saying and the fact that he's
the reason that
not the only reason one of the main
reasons
that we haven't yet seen a bill passed
is he the one playing games or is he
really so naive that he sees everybody
else as creating problems rather than
him
irony is dead and this is again another
reminder
in west virginia
you either get this or you get a
full-blown republican so the solution
isn't
to primary joe manchin
from an emotional standpoint maybe it is
maybe a lot of people would feel good
primarying joe manchin if somehow
uh someone to his left wins the primary
then they lose the general
and that seat gets flipped from democrat
to republican okay maybe some people
would feel good about that because they
would feel like he lost his seat it's a
punishment to him
as we talked about with bill share and
uh and and with members of the audience
over the last couple of weeks
the real solution is you got to flip
republican seats to democrats i continue
to maintain that's the solution if you
disagree with me let me know
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right i think you're
really gonna like this clip or at least
be horrified by it in a sense that will
be sort of enjoyable but horrifying um
we've talked about the kind of like
manufactured nature of the culture wars
that the wright is currently engaged in
and the manufacture manufactured can
mean a couple different things
manufactured can be manufactured by
creating irrational fear
um
through lying to people and making them
think that something is a threat to
their way of life or to their family or
whatever so it could be manufactured
with lies to create fear um it can also
be considered manufactured in that it's
sort of like just based on either
misunderstandings or
factual discrepancies like about the
2020 election the big lie it's
unconstitutional
and states violated the rules and dead
people voted and mike pillow has access
to voting machines that show you all
these different things um and it becomes
sort of a cultural thing where even
though you might say well what's the
culture of claiming the election was
lost it's this cultural fight where they
see themselves as engaged in a war
where it doesn't matter if they
literally believe the explanations as to
how the election was stolen they see
repeating that it was stolen as being on
the right team and fighting this holy
war of sorts quite frankly one of the
flashpoints so many of the flashpoints
in this include critical race theory
war on christmas
communism and socialism coming to
america
um
you could you could argue the biden
dementia thing is part of the culture
battle um the big lie certainly there's
a whole list of these things and we we
can go on and talk about them critical
race theory is particularly interesting
because
even more per in in an even more
pronounced way than with socialism and
communism the people talking about it
don't even know what it means oh all the
vaccine stuff also would be another
element of this a lot of the people
saying critical race theory is just a
disaster they literally have no idea
what it is they have no idea what it
means they don't understand what it
means in context out of context they
just have no clue
this is a video that has gone viral
from the good liars who do these really
really great interviews the good liars
interviewed a virginia voter as many of
you know today is election day in
virginia we're going to be covering the
results live of the gubernatorial race
terry mcauliffe versus um
uh glenn younkin who's the republican
candidate
very important race and there are really
important issues at stake the good liars
went and interviewed this guy uh
air force veteran at least according to
the hat the guy is wearing and said
what's the most important issue and the
guy said it's critical race theory and
when asked what it is the guy literally
has no idea what it is he just doesn't
know what's going on take a look at this
what's the most important issue in the
governor's race here in virginia getting
back to the basics of teaching children
not teaching them critical race theory
now
before even getting to the question what
is critical race theory
it's not very small government
conservativey
to want the governor
to necessarily dictate school curriculum
i mean remember these republicans claim
to have this principle they abide by
which is
you only involve government in
everything when absolutely necessary if
not you leave things leave it to school
boards leave it to municipalities leave
it right but here they want to elect
glenn younkin who has made a big deal
out of we got to get critical race
theory out and all these different
things completely in violation of their
so-called
light touch conservative principles but
then here comes the question what is
critical race theory and
what is critical race theory
well i'm not going to get into the
specifics of it because i don't
understand it that much but it's
something that i don't the what little
bit that i know i don't care for and and
what have you heard that you don't well
i'm not gonna
you know
i don't uh
i don't i don't have that much knowledge
on it but it's something that i'm not
that i don't care for you know this is
like when a kid
is presented with
you know broccolini for the first time
and the kid says
i don't like it i'm not trying it but
what about it don't you like you it
doesn't it doesn't taste good or you
don't like the tech i've never tried it
i don't like it i don't want it
okay right but what
i don't care for it the little i know
about it which is the fact that you're
trying to feed it to me
not good
i don't like it
it's a similar dynamic well maybe inform
yourself about what it is first and our
friend anna casparian over at the young
turks had a really good tweet about
sort of another aspect so how many
layers are there to this there's a lot
of layers there's people who are just
goaded into culture war issues by fear
and propaganda that's one aspect two the
general incompetence of the american
public which we will get to in the
voicemail segment
three is what anna tweeted which is this
is what manufactured culture wars
meant to distract you from elites
robbing this country blind
results in and folks like this guy they
would probably agr if a republican says
corporations are robbing you blind they
would probably agree in some general
sense to the extent that they understand
it
um if a republican said
you know even climate change is an issue
of patriotism like they would go for it
but very quickly all of those
substantive issues
including issues on which there aren't
big differences between republicans and
democrats who are part of the same
system that is not working for tens of
millions if not more
of americans
they get distracted with something like
critical race theory which this guy even
admits that he doesn't even know what it
means so
sad
funny depressing
kafka-esque to go back to the earlier
segment
you tell me how you would describe it
hey this is really interesting we've
been following this
we can call it a hypocrisy we can call
it a double standard we can call it a
contrast
between the things said on fox news
about vaccine mandates and requirements
and the policies of fox news as a
company now most famously joe biden said
hey
we need mandatory vaccine or test every
week
fox news has done something even
stricter and fox news says mandatory
vaccine or test every day and wear masks
around wear masks around others if
you're not vaccinated and of course
people like tucker carlson and the fox
and friends people and jesse waters have
just said we don't have a mandate here
it's either not true fox and friends
said it's a protocol not a mandate etc
okay
we now have uh leaked information
from fox news's
um
health and safety
department as to the requirements for
their upcoming annual meeting this is
this is just amazing okay
2021 fox annual meeting of stockholders
health and safety protocols
look at the rules look at how strict
this is first of all if you have
symptoms of covid you got to stay home
okay fine they make that clear
um health screening
the designated stockholder entrance is
at particular address okay a prior to
admittance you have to show your ticket
to security and you've got to
participate in a health screening the
health screening will have the following
components stockholders will be asked to
complete an in-person symptom screening
and receive a negative test result
and present
verification that they are vaccinated
just to go to the stockholder meeting
you got to bring proof of vaccine
or acceptable proof of a negative
coveted test from 24 hours prior from
within 24 hours of going to the fox
studio lot
this is much stricter
than the us guidelines for coming back
to the us which say the test can be from
72 hours before fox says 24 hours
stricter
and or you have to disclose your
vaccination status are any of them going
to say our own company is violating
hipaa which it's not of course if during
the course of the health screening
process a stockholder doesn't provide
verification that they are fully
vaccinated or proof of a negative test
they will not be permitted entry and
will not be able to attend period
following the health screening
stockholders will be directed to the
designated law okay now look at this
on the fox studio lot
face coverings
all stockholders must wear facial
coverings while inside buildings
at all times
period
on the fox studio lot
if you do not have a facial covering a
fox representative will provide a mask
for you at no cost
hand sanitizing okay they'll have hand
sanitizer
social distancing
facial coverings do not replace the need
for physical distancing maintain six
feet from others when possible observe
social distancing directives etc at the
annual meeting stockholders should sit
in the designated seats and wear face
coverings at all times
breaks can be taken outside in the
designated area
okay
so fox news for their annual meeting
has a covet health screening for
everybody
you either must be vaccinated or have a
test within 24 hours
and you've got to wear a mask the entire
time
and they're saying biden's rules
are authoritarian now of course the
people saying that on air are not the
people making these decisions
but look at that contrast and i think
these fox hosts who continue to do this
stuff and say these things they need to
continually be confronted with this when
tucker was confronted with it he played
stupid first he said i don't speak for
fox and of course well you could just
speak as an employee you don't have to
speak as the people who came up with the
guidelines you can just speak as someone
who's subject to them and then he said
you know you can't force people to
disclose their hiv
status and say well no
that's different than
than saying whether you are vaccinated
saying whether you have a disease is
different also hiv is not contagious and
you know it went completely off the
rails it was a really great exposition
of how they have no leg to stand on it
needs to keep happening this is amazing
that fox is doing this i agree with all
of it i mean listen you got a big
stockholder meeting you don't want it to
be a super spreader event it's eminently
reasonable eminently reasonable that
this is what they are doing so check out
the full document it's only like a page
and a half two pages for yourself fox
coveted guidelines uh for their annual
shareholder meeting okay we've got a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p
this is going to be a harsh voicemail
yesterday during a live stream
of the first day of the kyle rittenhouse
murder trial i told my story of when i
was on a jury and i explained that
even for the minor assault case that i
was participating in the jury for
um two-thirds of the jury was
incompetent they did not understand the
simple instructions from the judge they
wanted to bring their own definitions of
things like self-defense and assault to
the jury and my point that i made
yesterday was listen there's a lot of
incompetent people to quote former
producer lewis 80 to 90 percent of
people aren't good at their jobs and
it's harsh and a lot of people get angry
because if you're you know it okay i
understand it um i got a voicemail that
that sort of plays on this idea and it's
harsh
but i i don't think it's inaccurate take
a listen
hey david it's angie in milwaukee
i just had to contact you after
listening to your story about jury duty
first of all i agree
the majority of people are really not
competent
to serve on a jury
why i say this is
because the people you described
sound an awful lot like the people i
work with every day
they're great nice people
but
the intelligence required
to think through a guilty versus not
guilty verdict and all the nuances of
that
they just don't have it
yeah i mean listen i
this is tough because i don't want to
make fun of people
but
the the issue
what was at issue in the jury i served
on was
was
someone punching someone else in the
face self-defense
and the judge made very clear there are
rules this was in massachusetts at the
time there are rules for what counts as
self-defense in the state
and you do have a duty to retreat
and if you could just turn around and
walk away from the situation
it's not self-defense and in the jury
room
four of the
six people two just had no clue what was
going on but two insisted now if someone
comes up to you and says something like
this
you punch him in the face that's
self-defense man that's self-defense
and it ended up being like a six seven
hour deliberation which shocked the
judge it shocked the lawyers it shocked
everybody
and this was really really simple and so
when we think about the kyle rittenhouse
trial
and we listen to a lot of the things
that were said by potential jurors and
even people who made it onto the jury
yesterday
um i know that a lot of people like to
say it's not a perfect system but it's
the best system we have you're judged by
a jury of your peers
i'm not saying i have a better idea for
how it should be done
but there's a lot of incompetent people
making what are for others life and
death decisions not literally in the
sense of the death penalty all the time
but
going to prison for 10 20 years that's a
life and death decision in the sense of
it impacts your life for the rest of
your life
um and i don't know any way to put it
politely but it's a very very scary
situation we have on today's bonus show
we're going to hear about producer pat's
road trip down to florida where he's
going to be for the next couple months
we are going to hear about you know the
protesters uh the strikers rather
uh john deere striking employees have
gotten
a pretty damn good offer from john deere
it actually seems like some of these
strikes may be having positive outcomes
we'll also talk about pennsylvania
offering state employees five days of
paid leave for getting vaccinated all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at jointman.com and get
instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman